SHORT DAYS.
WE'LL HAVE MORE OF MY MONOLOGUE
IN A MINUTE BUT FORMER CHIEF OF
STAFF RYAN PREVIS AND CHARLIE
HURT.
RYAN, LET'S GET YOUR REACTION.
THIS IS ALL THEY HAVE AND
NOTHING POSITIVE THEY CAN RUN ON
AND NOT A SINGLE THING.
NOW THE QUESTION IS, WILL THIS
STRATEGY OF SLANDER, SMEAR,
BESMUDGERMENT AND CHARACTER
ASSASSINATION, WILL THAT WORK?
>> IT'S NOT GOING TO WORK AT ALL
BECAUSE I DO THINK THAT THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE SEE THAT OUR
ECONOMY IS IN THE TANK AND GAS
IS UP AND BORDER IS NOT SECURE
BUT THIS IS WHAT THEY'VE GOT AND
THEY'VE DECIDED THAT SINCE THEY
HAVE NOTHING, THEY'VE GOT
RIDICULE AND AS ZELENSKY, I'VE
BEEN FOLLOWING THIS THING SINCE
OBAMA.
ALINSKI SAID RIDICULE IS MAN'S
BEST WEAPON AND THAT'S WHAT
THEY'RE DOING.
THEY'RE TARGETING PEOPLE,
THEY'RE POLARIZING PEOPLE,
THEY'RE PERSONALIZING IT, AND
THEY'RE GOING AFTER REPUBLICANS
WITH THESE INSANE ATTACKS AND
WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT FASCISM, PUT
ASIDE THE FASCISM OF JOE BIDEN
THROUGH EXECUTIVE ORDER SHUTTING
KEYSTONE PIPELINE, SHUTTING DOWN
THE MARKET AND DOING ALL THE
THINGS HE'S DONE.
WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT PURGING A
PARTY OF DISEASE, THAT SOUNDS
LIKE FASCIST LANGUAGE TO ME.
YOU HAVE THESE CANDIDATES OUT
THERE AND TALK ABOUT FASCISM,
MANDELA BARNES IN WASHINGTON
RUNNING AGAINST RON JOHNSON
TALKING ABOUT RELEASING 50% OF
THE STATE'S PRISONERS.
FETTERMAN, YOUR BUDDY IN
PENNSYLVANIA, SEAN, IS TALKING
ABOUT RELEASING 30% OF THE
STATE'S PRISONERS.
IT DOESN'T GET ANYMORE WILD THAN
THAT.
AND FINALLY WHEN JOE BIDEN COMES
TO WISCONSIN AND PENNSYLVANIA, S
AS NUTS AS THAT PLATFORM SOUNDS,
THOSE TWO CANDIDATES DIDN'T WANT
TO GO BY JOE BIDEN BECAUSE HE'S
UNPOPULAR AND THE ECONOMY IS IN
THE TANK AND PEOPLE KNOW IT.
>> Sean: CHARLIE, IF THIS
ELECTION BECOMES ABOUT RECORD
HIGH INFLATION, RECORD HIGH GAS
PRICES, RECORD HIGH PRICES FOR
EVERYTHING YOU BUY AND EVERY
STORE YOU GO TO, IF IT BECOMES
ABOUT LAW AND ORDER AND SAFETY
AND SECURITY, IF IT'S ABOUT
EDUCATION OF OUR KIDS, IF IT'S
ABOUT ALL OF THESE THINGS AND
NOT ABOUT THE ATTACKS AND NAME
CALLING AND DEMONIZATION OF ANY
CONSERVATIVE OR REPUBLICAN, I
SAY REPUBLICANS WIN IF THAT'S
WHAT THEY RUN ON.
NOW THE QUESTION S WHICH SIDE
WILL WIN THE NARRATIVE?
>> YEAH, I THINK YOU'RE EXACTLY
RIGHT ABOUT THAT AND THAT'S
EXACTLY WHY YOU HAVE DEMOCRATS
MALIGNING AND INSUNLIGHT HALF OF
THE COUNTRY -- INSULTING HALF OF
THE COUNTRY EVERY TIME THEY TALK
AND OF COURSE THERE'S NOTHING IN
THE WORLD THAT'S MORE FASCIST
THAN HAVING A PRESIDENT CALLING
HALF OF THE PEOPLE HE WORKS FOR
FASCIST OR SEMI-FASCIST.
OR HAVING THE FORMER FIRST LADY
TALK ABOUT HOW OUR VOTERS IN
THIS COUNTRY HER POLITICAL
OPPONENTS THAT DON'T SUPPORT HER
ARE SOMEHOW A DISEASE IN THE
COUNTRY.
THIS IS REALLY SICK LANGUAGE AND
THIS KIND OF EFFORT TO
DE-HUMANIZE PEOPLE IS WHAT
FASCISTS DO.
THE ONLY FASCISTS HERE ARE
HILLARY CLINTON AND JOE BIDEN
BUT YOU'RE EXACTLY RIGHT.
THEY HAVE ABSOLUTELY NOTHING TO
RUN ON.
THEY CONTROL EVERY LEVER OF
POWER IN WASHINGTON.
BOTH CHAMBERS OF CONGRESS AND
THE WHITE HOUSE.
THEY CAN RUN THE TABLES AND DO
WHATEVER THEY WANT AND WHAT THEY
HAVE DONE SO FAR HAS BEEN TO
DESTROY THE COUNTRY AND YOU'VE
GONE THROUGH ALL OF THE
IMPORTANT THINGS WHETHER IT'S
SKYROCKETING CRIME, GAS PRICES,
INFLATION, OPEN BORDER, MISERY
AROUND THE WORLD, TERRORISM
TAKING A NEW ROUTE IN PLACES
LIKE AFGHANISTAN.
SO THEY HAVE NOTHING ELSE TO RUN
ON.
BUT I THINK YOU'RE EXACTLY
RIGHT.
SEAN.
THESE THINGS, PEOPLE, IT'S NOT
JUST CONSERVATIVES AND
REPUBLICANS WHO WANT THEIR
FAMILIES TO BE SAFE OR WANT TO
BE ABLE TO AFFORD GASOLINE.
DEMOCRAT VOTERS WANT THAT TOO.
AND AS LONG AS REPUBLICANS
REMAIN LASER FOCUSED ON THAT AND
TALK ABOUT THE IDEAS THAT WE ALD
THAT DONALD TRUMP TALKED ABOUT,
THEN REPUBLICANS ARE GOING TO
WALK AWAY WITH THIS THING IN TWO
YEARS AND REPUBLICANS ARE GOING
TO WALK AWAY EVEN BIGGER OR NEXT
MONTH.
THEY'RE GOING TO WALK AWAY WITH
IT AND EVEN BIGGER IN TWO YEARS.
>> Sean: SO, RYAN, YOU HAD
GREAT SUCCESS AT RNC CHAIR.
WHAT DO YOU TELL PEOPLE RUNNING
FOR THE HOUSE, RUNNING FOR THE
SENATE?
MY UNDERSTANDING IS NEXT WEEK
THAT KEVIN MCCARTHY WILL LAY OUT
HIS VERSION OF A CONTRACT WITH
AMERICA COMMITMENTS TO AMERICA,
I LIKE THAT IDEA.
I LIKE THE IDEA THAT EVERY
CANDIDATE SIGNS THEIR NAME AND
MAKES A PLEDGE TO DO CERTAIN
THINGS BEFORE THEY RUN.
I WOULD LIKE THE SENATE
CANDIDATES TO DO THE SAME.
WHAT DO REPUBLICANS NEED TO DO
TO KEEP THE FOCUS WHERE IT
BELONGS?
>> WELL, I AGREE WITH YOU TOO .
I THINK NUMBER ONE, YOU GOT TO
TELL PEOPLE WHAT YOU'RE FOR AND
A CONTRACT WITH AMERICA OR A NEW
CONTRACT IS WHATEVER YOU'RE
GOING TO CALL IT IS BRILLIANT
NUMBER ONE AND NUMBER TWO, CAN'T
LET THE CANDIDATES LIKE MANDELA
BARNES AND FETTERMAN GET AWAY AS
PORTRAYING THEMSELVES AS
SOMETHING THEY'RE NOT.
THEY'RE ON TV EVERY MINUTE
TELLING PEOPLE THEY'RE
MAINSTREAM WHILE AT THE SAME
TIME THEY'RE TALKING ABOUT
RELEASING PRISONERS AND TALKING
ABOUT DEFUNDING THE POLICE AND
THEY'RE ON THE RECORD TALKING
ABOUT CASHLESS BAIL THAT PEOPLE
WHO COMMIT VIOLENT CRIMES SHOULD
NOT HAVE TO PAY A CASH BAIL IN
ORDER TO GET OUT OF PRISON.
THIS IS WHAT THEIR RECORD IS.
REPUBLICANS HAVE TO BE
RELENTLESS IN WHAT THEY'RE FOR
AND POINTING OUT WHAT THEIR
OPPONENT IS FOR AND TELL THEIR
OWN STORY ABOUT THEIR OWN LIVES
AND OWN FAMILIES AND THEIR OWN
SACRIFICES AND ALL THAT TOGETHER
IS IMPORTANT AND FOCUS ON THE
GROUPED GAME AND GRASS ROOTS.
GOT TO FOCUS ON ABSENTEE BALLOT,
REQUEST FORMS, TARGETING PEOPLE,
TURNING OUT VOTERS AND OBVIOUSLY
LIKE LINCOLN SAID HAVE MORE
BALLOTS IN THE BOX THAN THE
OTHER GUY.
>> Sean: DO YOU FEEL THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY HAS THAT
TECHNOLOGY AND COMPARED TO
COMPETE WITH THE DEMOCRATS ON
THAT LEVEL IN TERMS OF GETTING
OUT THE VOTE?
>> I DO, SEAN, AND I THINK WE'VE
ALSO LEARN ADD LESSON ABOUT
VOTING AND ELECTION INTEGRITY
AND NOT WAITING UNSTILL AFTER
THE ELECTION TO DO SOMETHING
ABOUT IT.
I THINK THAT'S ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT'S CHANGED OVERS LAST COUPLE
OF YEARS.
>> Sean: CHARLIE, WE'LL GIVE
YOU THE LAST WORD.
>> YEAH, THE MOST IMPORTANT
THING THEY HAVE TO FOCUS ON
PERSONAL SECURITY, CRIME, AND
THE ECONOMY AND THE BORDER.
IF REPUBLICANS FOCUS ON THOSE
THREE THINGS AND HIT THESE
PEOPLE AS HARD AS THEY CAN ABOUT
THE FACT THAT THEY HAVE BEEN FOR
OPEN BOARDERS, NO BAIL,
LAWLESSNESS, THEY'VE SPORTED THE
RIOTS FOR TWO YEARS AS LONG AS
REPUBLICANS STAY ON THAT, I
THINK THEY'LL HAVE A GOOD